let's talk about how to get rid of
plantar fasciitis
and to do it instantly the problem with
this condition
is the treatments that people go through
they put you on pain medications
steroids which have massive side effects
they do needle injections
then you do orthotics i mean here's the
thing i had flat feet
so i was raised on orthotics every
different orthotic
i had it it never helped let's take a
mold of your flat foot and then so you
can walk on your flat foot and it was
until i got rid of my orthotics that i
started getting relief in my feet then
you have splinting at night holding your
foot in a certain position through the
night and there's also botulism toxin
injections and if that doesn't work we
have
faciatomy which sounds like lobotomy but
it's taking out part of your fascia okay
so they cut the fascia
to release the tension
to
hopefully get rid of the pain well what
about the scar tissue that grows in
there and what about the root cause of
fasciitis
now i did a video on plantar fasciitis a
while ago and i'm just going to read you
a few of the comments
on this video because i taught them a
very counter-intuitive
technique to get rid of pain from
plantar fasciitis and you just have to
hear the results it'll actually blow you
away and then i'm going to show you how
to do this technique all right check
this out i've tried everything i'm
sitting on my couch crying because
i did all the stretches
that i taught her of course and feel no
heel pain now i can't remember the last
time i could walk without hobbling all
right next one unbelievable pain went
from a ten to a zero next day of doing
this years of pain
thank you next one i've had plantar
fasciitis for about three months my pain
level was about at eight when i watched
this video i was a little skeptical
because it goes against everything i
have watched with nothing to lose i
tried the exercises
my pain has dropped to a one all right
here's another one like many others i
was skeptical i watched this and tried
the exercises i've had heel pain for
over
10 years there were days i literally
crawled around my house on all fours
from not being able to put my feet down
after one of these exercises my heels
feel better i went from an eight to a
two thank you for going against the
trend how about this one i did the
stretch 10 times while watching your
video my pain vanished thank you dr eric
all right so i'm going to show you how
to do this step one you have to rate
your pain from 0
to 10 10 being very severe
zero being no pain so go ahead and write
that down right now because we're going
to re-rate that after this very simple
stretch all right this is what you need
to know
the absolute worst thing you can do
is to stretch
the fascia okay like in stretching your
calves this is what everyone does this
is how they do the splints they do it in
this stretch where your foot is going
upwards i mean think about it here you
have this inflamed fascia which is this
connective tissue underneath your foot
right it's inflamed why would you ever
want to stretch it more there's already
probably micro trauma going on and if
we're going to stretch it more we're
just going to re-injure it you never
want to stretch with your foot going up
like you're stretching the calf
when you have plantar fasciitis what you
want to do is you want to stretch the
opposite muscles and i'm going to
explain why in a minute now there's a
couple ways you can do this
what i recommend to start out with is
just sit with your foot crossed okay
you're sitting down just cross your foot
and grab your toes okay
and stretch your foot going downward
okay so in other words you're not
stretching your calf
you're stretching the muscles on the
front part of your shin that muscle is
called the anterior tibialis so you're
stretching your foot down okay you're
gonna stretch it relax it
stretch it relax it
stretch it relax it just do that 10
times
right now now as you're stretching
i want to tell you something
anytime you have an injury like
inflammation underneath your foot
and you stretch the opposite muscle
what's going to happen you're going to
send
signals
on the opposite side because any time
you contract a muscle there is a circuit
that connects this muscle with the
opposing muscle so to allow movement
when we contract one muscle the opposite
muscle must relax and must lengthen or
else you couldn't have motion but as you
stretch the muscle the same thing
happens what you're doing with the
stretch
is you're sending signals to the bottom
of your foot okay and your calf
to relax that's all you're doing all
right so it should be about 10 times
right now
go ahead and write down what your pain
rating is right now if you're doing this
correctly it should have significantly
decreased
and please put that in the comments
section so you want to do this a few
times a day every day for about two
weeks that's the stretch but there's
other things you're going to do as well
all right let's go to number two
you want to avoid
pro-inflammatory
foods and things that
are considered food but are really not
food now if you take a look at junk food
it's really made out of three things
refined flour refined sugar and refined
oils now they call it refined oils
vegetable oils but they're they have
nothing to do with vegetables okay
they're not vegetables they're seeds but
vegetable oil sounds a lot better i mean
what are you gonna do like squeeze a
carrot or lettuce and try to pull oil
out of there that's not what happens
what they do with seed oils is to
extract oil from the seed you have to
put these seeds under tremendous
pressure
with solvents like hexane which can be
toxic to your nervous system and you
have to put them under very high heats
so refined flour refined sugar and
definitely refined grain oils
are the culprit
to a lot of your inflammation in your
body
but the big one that a lot of people do
not put emphasis on is the vegetable
oils i'm talking about soy oil corn oil
canola oil
cotton seed oil these are highly
inflammatory and they create major
health problems not just inflammation
they lead to
gaining weight obesity they lead to
heart disease they shorten your life
there's studies that show linking to
gaining cancer so it wasn't very long
ago that we
switched our fats in our foods okay we
used to use saturated fats okay like
butter
lard
talo and now we do all this processed
vegetable oils now i know you're saying
you know you don't use vegetables right
you don't have
uh corn oil sitting in your cupboard but
here's the thing in america 20 of your
calories is coming from these
so-called vegetable oils 20
for an average person and let me tell
you where they're hidden they're hidden
in mayonnaise
salad dressing any food that's either
canned or boxed or processed they're fed
to animals in their animal feeds that
you end up eating and they're in pretty
much every single restaurant that you go
to these restaurants do not cook with
butter or olive oil they use soy and
corn and canola unfortunately
so if you're going out to dinner a lot
and you feel more plantar fasciitis then
we know why now what happens with these
omega-6 fatty acids which are
pro-inflammatory is they start to
replace
certain healthy fats inside your cell
membranes in other words they get lodged
in the cells and it creates a situation
where it's very very difficult to get
these oils out
it actually takes about four years
to
detox these oils out of your cells to
get them out of your body because
they're so locked in to every single
cell membrane so when you switch your
diet and start to get rid of these oils
and use more saturated fats
whether you're cooking or consuming
butter
coconut oil avocado is a good oil and
especially olive oil it's going to take
about four years to completely get these
oils out of your body and the amount of
oxidation that's occurring because
they're very very fragile in your body
is astronomical it's creating so much
free radical damage
in its inflammatory process not to
mention every single one of these oils
is gmo which means they probably have
traces of glyphosate which is an
herbicide and traces of hexane which is
another toxin that i'm not going to get
into in this video but i'm emphasizing
this because in practice
i would say a hundred percent of the
people coming in with plantar fasciitis
were consuming annoyingly a tremendous
amount of this oil and
as soon as we made the switch and switch
these fats
there is significant improvement
not just in inflammation but in all
sorts of health related issues all right
the next thing you could do for some
quick relief is start taking vitamin d3
if it's winter if it's a summer you go
outside you get a lot of sun because
vitamin d3 is one of the most powerful
anti-inflammatory and i wouldn't just
take you know 600 ius
which is the rda i would take
minimally 10 000 i use but preferably 20
000 i use but you're going to find
probably within a few hours that any
inflammation in your body whether it's
in the bottom of your foot or your back
is going to start to vanish all right
and the last thing that creates a lot of
inflammation is frequent eating so i
highly recommend you start intermittent
fasting and you're going to find that
too is going to create a huge effect in
your inflammation not to mention other
things like weight your mood your
cognitive function
and your energy now for those of you
that want the best anti-inflammatory
diet
i'm going to put it right here there's
actually a series or a playlist of a few
videos that you need to watch check it
out i put it right here